[Music]
do
so
[Applause]
[Music]
so
hello
good evening
welcome to the table
my name
and um
yeah i'm just so excited to see you
people here in person
whether you are um
this is my face just so you'll know i
just
brett was like let them see your smile
and i was like okay
that didn't happen but here i am
whether you are here in person or you
are
attending online or you're listening to
this on thursday
i'm so i'm so glad
i have a special affinity in love for
the people who are attending online as
my husband josh and i were regular in
online attendees when we lived in
chattanooga tennessee
for two years
and or we lived there for nine years but
we attended the table for two years
online and
that's my husband josh
he was in chattanooga with me
and
it just became this really special thing
and in august we actually packed up our
family and moved back to texas to be
closer to family here in texas but also
because we fell in love with this
community we were asked to lead an
online meetup group from other people
who are attending online and scattered
all over the u.s
and we were like sure we can we can
facilitate that and figure out someone
that can lead and take over and we'll
just kind of you know quietly step out
of that role because we're going to be
in chattanooga so you want people that
can be in person
we fell in love with these people and
we're like these are real people and
there's just something about the
heartbeat of this church that's
attracting
like-minded people and as i was thinking
about that with any group like if you're
joining a knitting group you're there
because you like knitting or running
because you like running homeschooling
you homeschool your kids and i feel like
something with the table it's not just
this like-mindedness of people who are
seeking jesus and love
and
biblical truth it's like woundedness
and um
i as our group we spent six or eight
weeks with people sharing their
testimonies and the theme of every story
was these deep wounds but it wasn't just
that because we all have it but people
being willing and being vulnerable and
that is the heartbeat of
the table and it has been such a gift
and on friday i was with another little
meetup group that we just started let me
know if you want to join it's super fun
and we're going through a brene brown
book and then we're going to go hiking
every other week so it's going to be
great let me know if you want to join
and one of the other women in this
meetup on friday she leads an in-person
meetup group and she was saying the
exact same thing about the heartbeat of
people sharing their stories
they're really raw and hard and a lot of
really sad but a lot of really resilient
and brave and bold people sharing their
stories so i'm just so thankful for this
community so whether you're here in
person
online or you're just tuning in or you
stumbled upon this church because you
googled it or you googled the word
inclusivity and you found us i'm so glad
you're here this is truly a spot that
has been designed
for you because of you for jesus because
of jesus
and it's good i'm glad glad you're here
i'm glad to be here in person
and for you online i love y'all um
i have two announcements so there's this
really big cultural annual event going
on in america it's called the super bowl
and it's happening february
13th so our church service is actually
gonna meet at four o'clock
that sunday be done at five o'clock so
you can be home by 5 30 to watch the
super bowl or watch the halftime show
whichever whichever comes first i don't
know
i'm just kidding
the game comes first
my second announcement is on february
20th there is going to be a welcome to
the table class where if you're wanting
to learn more about who the table is or
if you want to become an official member
you can come to that and
our pastor brett will be leading it so
you can also just if you want to hang
out with him you could show up to that
if you're interested in any of those
things or more information about meetups
there's a little card table outside the
door you can fill out your information
and just put a little star by what
you're most interested in and we'd love
to plug you in
um and get to know you and hear your
story those real and raw stories that
are the heartbeat of this church the
heartbeat of jesus
yeah so as we get ready to be together
tonight and worship and
listen to god's good word i'm gonna pray
and we will
begin god thank you so much
thank you for this this community thank
you for the um the hearts that went
before us to create this and birth it
out of um
of that real raw messy messiness as
humans and just seeking a place where we
can come together and
not just linger in the raw real messy
hurt sad
but to come together and take that and
form something beautiful
to glorify you
to know you to seek you to honor you to
love one another and i just i thank you
for a community that is truly moving to
that rhythm that is the culture here it
is the pace here and i um just thank you
for each person who has chosen to
bravely show up and be sitting here
tonight or listening online
and i pray god that they would find you
tonight
that they would find you on thursday if
that's when they're listening to this
and that it would um bless them that it
would inspire them that it would
encourage them and that
that they would find a meetup group that
they would find real community here that
they would find a friend
and feel known and loved and worthy
because they are because you are um i
just praise you for all the hearts here
the hearts online god you are good
you are love we need you we worship you
amen
amen thank you kelly
all right you guys we're like she said
really glad you're here we all stand
with us we're gonna start out with a
song called oh how i need you by all
sons and daughters it's one of my
favorite groups who is no longer
together so
r.i.p
but jesse's going to get us started so
you guys join in as you are able
[Music]
lord the
seeking lord i find you
in the doubt
and to know you
is
[Music]
to know
so
little
[Music]
oh
lord i find you in the seeking
[Music]
is
oh
[Music]
how i need you
oh how i need
[Music]
lord i find you in the morning
lord i seek you
every day
let my life be for your glory
woven in
you
oh how i need
[Music]
wow
like glorious light i will go where you
shine break the dawn break the sky make
the way bright before me in your life i
will find all i need all i need is you
oh
like glorious light i will go where you
shine break the dawn crack the sky and
make the way bright before me in your
life i will find all i need all i need
is
[Music]
oh
oh how i need
[Music]
i wanna know you lord
like i know a friend
i wanna know you
[Music]
i lord know you lord
like i know what
i wanna know you lord
so i'm laying down
all my religions
[Music]
i wanna know
and i used to think
that i could box
[Music]
but i'm laying down
we want to know
[Music]
lord i've been told
to be ashamed
i don't measure up
lord i've been told
i'm not good enough
but you're here with me
i'll reach out and you
find me
[Music]
and you see no amount of untruths
could separate
[Music]
i'll reach out and you
find me
[Music]
can separate
i reach out and you
find me
in
[Music]
gospel
and i will rejoice
is
[Music]
me
i reach out and you
find me
[Music]
and you see no amount of
unshoes
can separate
[Music]
us
i reach out and you
find me
[Music]
and you say no amount
in the simple gospel
i will rejoice
in you
lord
and i will rejoice
in the simple gospel
i will rejoice
[Music]
yes thank you god
good thank you jesse
all right so um
now we're going to move into our prayers
of the people
and so i'll be reading off the screen
and the words in red if you guys would
just say those parts out loud
um i'll pause for you
all right
all right for for the city of saxi and
for every city and community and all
those who live in them
we pray to you
for the good earth that you have given
us
and the wisdom and will to conserve it
we pray to you
for those who travel on land sea
or air
we pray to you
for the old and the sick
for the widow and the orphan
for the injured and the suffering
we pray to you
for the poor and oppressed the
unemployed and destitute
for prisoners and captives and for all
who remember and care for them
we pray to you
lord we know that you love us
and you hear us and so
we lift these names and situations
up to you
[Music]
from online james's mom ongoing chemo
and medical procedures
and all of those who are dealing with
mental health struggles
[Music]
lord
for the names and moments we have spoken
aloud and for those we have kept in our
hearts
we pray to you
that they may have life and light
healing and hope
peace
and a deep sense of your presence
amen
[Music]
so
scott thank you so much for meeting us
in this space
thank you that we can come to you
without having it figured out
without knowing all the right answers or
even knowing sometimes how we feel
but that we can bring our whole selves
all our burdens
all the people that we're carrying
all the heaviness and we can lay it down
knowing god that others will lift it up
with us
and that you are always
lifting our heads
carrying the weight with us
[Music]
i've carried a burden
too long on my
[Music]
i hear your invitation
to let it all go
and i see you now
i'm laying it down
and
[Music]
no reason
again
[Music]
you saw my condition
you had a plan
from the start
your son for redemption
the price for my heart
and i don't have a context
for that kind of love
i don't
understand and i can't
[Music]
i'm done with the hiding
again
[Music]
long before my
first breath
and running into
your
arms is
[Music]
again
oh
[Music]
thank you god
for who you are in our lives
you are not only our beginning our
starting place our creator our maker you
are not only the one who shaped us and
formed us but you are also the one that
carries us through
you are also a friend
[Music]
the one who listens to our heart
and hears our cries
the one who heals our wounds
redeems our darkness
you are the one who put the light inside
of us to begin with and you are the one
who calls it out
and continues to see it
to see the good
[Music]
to show us who we really are
god keep creating us keep making us
into the people you created
the people you called
[Music]
and purposed
and planned
[Music]
you are good god and we invite you into
this space with us open our ears to hear
what's on your heart
what you've put on brett's heart tonight
[Music]
we love you and we thank you for this
time together
in jesus name
amen
thank you guys so much if you all want
to have a seat brett's going to get us
started on the message and as you're
doing that just turn to someone around
you
say hello make them feel welcome we are
so glad to be together
well good evening everyone
grace and peace
my name is brett and uh it's really
great to be with you really really good
and i want to um also welcome those
joining us online
love y'all lots and and anyone who's new
here kind of you know plugging in
finding your way
into the community that's a that's a
really great thing so
um
we are we're in a series titled first
peter part two we're just walking our
way through this remarkable little book
uh from the new testament and um it's
been cool i like
um i like that it kind of pushes us into
different areas different topics and
things um
so tonight the title of the message is
uh how christians upended the world
how christians upended the world and um
we're going to be in first peter chapter
2 verses 13 through 17.
so if you've got your bibles you can
follow along or it will be on the screen
and um remember back in the day when
people had to bring their bibles to
church i remember feeling like weird if
i didn't have my bibles like oh no how
am i going to read you know now
got the screens
even our backup our phone is our backup
bible isn't even if these were to go out
we're like oh don't worry i brought my
own screen it's pretty great
so all right verse 13.
peter writes for the lord's
sake
submit to all human authority whether
the king as the head of the state or the
officials he has appointed for the king
has sent them um to punish those who do
wrong and to honor those who do right
verse 15. it is god's will that your
honorable lives should silence those
ignorant people who make foolish
accusations
against you
uh keep in mind they're facing the
church is facing a lot of persecution
right now in in rome um
and in the roman provinces i mean rome
owned most of the world or at least of
the western world this time
uh those foolish accusations against you
verse 16 for you are free
yet you are god's slaves so don't use
your freedom as an excuse to do evil
respect everyone love the family of
believers fear god and respect the king
so um if you were here last week then
you know in terms of um context one of
the the great themes of the book of
first peter is um is this idea
that to be um in step with christ
means that
not even just i was gonna say at times
but consistently um
maybe even at times more often than not
that means you will at some level be
kind of out of step with the broader
culture
and kind of hovering in the background
of this this passage um
is uh well it's it's a lot of things we
we kind of touched on last week so um
basically christians at this time for
those who weren't here let me catch you
up so christians were um kind of seen
viewed by by people in rome as um
as being somewhat unpatriotic
because right the roman empire as i just
mentioned it was kind of this vast you
know network um of uh
of cities and i mean they just owned
huge you know regions of land and so um
people within them kind of they needed a
way to unify the empire
and so what they did was something
called the imperial cult
um and the imperial quote was basically
emperor worship um is the idea caesar is
lord
and um
of course christians you know christians
couldn't go along with that right
because for christians it's not caesar
is lord uh what is the what's the
statement
jesus is lord right
so
um and so this is kind of where we went
last week we looked at all these little
statements and phrases and ways that
christians were taking um what kind of
common turns of phrase in rome and
culture and were um taking titles and
things that were usually used to
describe caesar and they were taking all
those and then using them for jesus
so you can see how this would be
sort of like
you know people were starting to cast
that kind of sideways glance at those
christians like they're just um
you know christians were viewed as like
just not in step you know it's like you
ever had uh maybe a group of like
friends like a friend group and you know
you kind of had like a certain vibe and
a certain culture a certain way of being
certain language you use certain
traditions you know and then if you have
someone who like joins but they're like
and they're like cool i mean they're
like kind of hard but then they're just
keep
you know kind of throwing off the groove
a little bit and that was christians
like just kinda i mean they're
they they love us they're like here and
yet they're like different
you know so that's the background
that's the the context um of what
peter's writing and um you know because
of this this kind of certain kind of
unpatriotic streak you you might sort of
question like well i mean how far did
christians take that like were they
you know like kind of political
revolutionaries you know kind of
fomenting
um
[Music]
i don't know like a certain unrest in
rome right because um i mean
if if for example
it's the ideas jesus is lord not caesar
well like how far do you push that logic
out
right and how much do you try to
undermine caesar now
from the passage we just read
you can tell like peter doesn't really
go there right in some intense way he
doesn't say like well because jesus is
lord and caesar's not opposed caesar and
his governors at every turn undermine
all their plans you know um that's not
where he goes right not at all somewhat
surprisingly honestly like if you
understand the historical background
that i just shared it's a little bit
surprising that he says
i mean basically like submit yourselves
to the human authorities that
are there
that are around you
now um i think it would be somewhat um
easy at this point it kind of asks the
question like well
knowing rome
and um
how terrible in a lot of ways roman
culture was
like is this the worst kind of political
quietism
like is that kind of where peter is
going like all the statements i mean it
seems like he's really bending over
backwards here to like don't cause any
trouble
you know and it's sort of like whoa
isn't there a time for christians to
cause some trouble
you know what i mean like isn't there a
time and a place for like
because i mean if you think about it um
like what was going on in rome rome was
like i say i kind of threw up big
statements like rome was terrible what
do i mean i mean like um
there was like the idea of kind of
slaves and um peasants being seen as
like less than human
um
you've got an incredibly patriarchal
culture like where um the patter
familias the kind of head of households
basically could rule
the family and kind of the extended
family with like an iron fist and
basically he had like all the rights
anyone underneath him especially like
slaves or women like they had almost no
rights um especially if they weren't
roman citizens like in the case of
slaves um i mean they could do literally
the head of the household could do
anything like physically sexually i mean
whatever they wanted with the people in
the household right it was sort of like
yeah it's just i mean you can imagine
this led to a lot of abuse and like it
was not good um and now this isn't even
touching on the military
which the roman military was um oh it's
terrible like it was actually it was
described there's a historian we'll
we'll touch on in just a second um but
he described the uh roman roman empire
as the tyrannosaurus rex of the ancient
world
and uh it was because it was just known
as being brutally violent um
in fact it didn't it didn't just like um
conquer people's
it like it was known to i mean it
exterminated people like
millions of people
and
uh if you think about it like the christ
that we worship this cross what are
these
what are those
those are roman instruments of torture
correct
like christ was one of those millions
i mean this and and why did they do this
because it was their whole value system
the whole roman value system just um
really lifted up and venerated power
like at the end of the day
um in their culture was understood as
natural and even
right for the strong to prey upon the
weak um violence and bloodlust was
called like
life it's like normal
um cunning and viciousness were revered
anger and revenge were seen as natural
victory and conquest the highest good in
fact i think there's times like we do
this now a lot through hollywood like
almost kind of lifting up and venerating
those kind of cultures like rome and
others in the ancient world um that were
kind of tyrannosaurus rex like i think
of i don't know i'm dating myself with
movies like this but like the movie 300
that came out back in the day you know a
spot where a spotter whatever leonidas
was yelling and you know and it's sort
of it's easy like you watch that or um
gladiator again totally dating myself
i'm 37 if you're wondering um
which is why i've been mentioning all
these um right and it's just sort of
it's these movies that where it's a lot
of violence and it's kind of like this
culture
that they're just
you know it's easy to look at them like
well
something kind they're kind of cool
you know it's kind of cool and um even
intellectuals like nietzsche and others
kind of found themselves longing for the
good old days that's kind of what they
started to think of it as like the you
know the time when men were men
it was that kind of stuff um this is
because it was this it was kind of known
as classical antiquity you know greece
roman values of where virtue but it was
virtue in a specific sense virtue as you
know power
and something and there's something that
at times people are kind of drawn to and
i think we kind of do our own version of
it with hollywood of kind of like yes
and when the reality is
i think if we can actually
see a culture like that resurrected um
it would strike us as morally repugnant
like that would be the at the end of the
day we just be like
and in fact um
it sort of would almost be like like
when we have those moments of nostalgia
for such a thing i think we're almost
like a kid like we have my nephew um
judah who loves
dinosaurs i kind of imagine him like if
he were to say like uncle brett i wish i
lived back in the day with dinosaurs i
wish i could see a t-rex and i would
know what he means like
that's adorable but no you don't
right like in reality like no no no none
of us like the idea of living back with
a dinosaur is like yeah so cool we could
be like living in jurassic park wait a
second that sounds horrible right and
that's sort of i think how this roman
nostalgia thing goes like we sort of
long for the good old days and it's like
i
don't know in fact there's a guy i've
been following now for a while tom
holland not spider-man
uh different tom holland jeff thank you
for pointing that out we were he was
working on my notes and as we're sitting
back there reviewing for the service
he's like when you start talking about
tom holland you might need to mention
that you're not talking about spider-man
and i was like that's a good catch
so not spider-man tom holland but this
would be um a historian
and he uh he's british and he's kind of
been on this trajectory where he was a
kid like he grew up he said he loved
like i mean he was kind of nerdy in his
own way not spider-man nerdy different
kind of angle nerdy he loved he loved
like julius caesar
you know alexander the great he just was
obsessed with that's eventually what led
him to do his phd work in kind of
classical antiquities and he just nerded
out over that whole world he adored it
um you know went deep studying it wrote
books on it um but he said but slowly
over time and by the way during this
this season like he had grown up
christian like as a kid but he like left
all that behind you know becoming an
academic and stuff it's not always
fashionable to be christian and so he
kind of left all that behind um and
became sort of i don't know agnostic
atheists kind of typical academic um and
he's but slowly what happened is the
more he learned about those cultures he
realized oh no
wait actually
he said i realized i couldn't relate to
a caesar augustus or a you know julius
caesar or alexander the great not only
could i not relate to them i can't even
respect them
it would be almost like venerating
hitler
you know like it's almost like we're
just not removed enough from not like
nazi germany or that would be obscene
for someone to be like yeah
you know it would be weird like huh and
yet to venerate rome
he has a quote this is from his book um
dominion
how the christian revolution remade the
world um he said
this talking about his his transition
because he's actually starting to come
back to his christian faith he started
attending church he hasn't like
converted yet but he's like right on the
cusp this is what he said he said was
not just the extremes of callousness
that unsettled me this would be like
during his studies
um but the complete lack of any sense
that the poor or the weak might have the
slightest intrinsic value why did i find
this so disturbing because in my morals
and ethics i was not spartan or roman at
all
that my belief in god had faded over the
course of my teenage years did not mean
that i had ceased to be christian
right in the sense of his values his
ethics
for a millennium and more the
civilization into which i had been born
was christendom assumptions i'd grown up
with about how society should be
properly organized the principles it
should uphold we're not bred of
classical antiquity still less of human
nature
but very distinctively of that
civilization's christian past
see what what's he what's he naming
he's naming
um
that those little christian communities
that the apostle peter's writing to
those little fledgling outposts of the
kingdom of god flung all over the roman
empire far and wide
that those little christian communities
ultimately lived a certain way
and over time
um
a revolution of values happened
what happened was right because if you
think of like those this is our whole
message last week was about the counter
cultural ways of christians in the roman
empire right they venerated and
worshipped not the cross building caesar
but the cross bearing christ
that's from theologian trip fuller i
should give full credit because that's a
good line isn't it
it's beautiful
not the cross building caesar the cross
bearing christ
they didn't they didn't lift up and
venerate the powerful
you know the um
war and glory and like their vision
was like at best war was sort of an
maybe a necessary evil
done reluctantly
like this wasn't something they're just
like yeah no
they were what were they lifting up they
were valuing the vulnerable the poor
the weak
these these were a peace loving people
these were the forgiveness and
reconciliation people not cunning and
viciousness
that was not their in what what happened
over time
those little communities
played out and they completely upended
and transformed
their world
and in over a few hundred years they
started to change rome
and within a few millennia
here we all sit just like the historian
tom holland whether we say the name
jesus
or not whether we're like god
or not
we have been
profoundly impacted
by that crucified messiah in the
movement he initiated
i mean our whole for the why because the
for the whole reason
that tom holland couldn't look up to a
julius caesar he couldn't be like yeah
it's so awesome like no
why because like deep in his bones
a certain transformation had taken place
his whole way of viewing the world
you see this brings us right back to our
original statement yes rome was cruel
not cool
cruel with an r
cruel and terrible
yes its values in theology absolutely
needed to be upended and yes
those early christian communities like
they stink and needed to do something
absolutely right
guess what
can you see it
they did
they did they lived their
counter-cultural peculiar strange ways
and within a few hundred years they up
in rome within a few thousand years they
change the course of western
civilization
and that's like that's not nothing
now we know the history we'll actually
get much more into this next week um
could that could could christians have
done better oh goodness yes like you
know like let's not pat ourselves in the
back too much just yeah you know those
are flawless no my goodness no we're a
mess
but
but there are so many values now that
the whole world in a way just takes for
granted you know human rights
you think rome was a big advocate for
human rights
no
right justice justice for the the poor
not gr is that sparta is sparta going
for that no
where's the esc christian
right christianity
that's those little communities
see peter and those early christians
turned the world upside down how did
they do it it was their living
it was their living
their their daily
example of living we know this from the
writings of the early church fathers
from gregory of nissa origen cyprian all
talk about this how over and over and
over it was just they're living in
families and communities that they live
their counter-cultural ways
and people were like astounded
and even though at first
thought it was strange over time
realized oh that's better
that's yeah
that's a better path like
um
if you're taking notes you can write
this down the early church's focus was
not on saving souls whether the soul of
a person or the soul of a nation their
focus was on living faithfully
i got that idea from a book called the
ferment um the quiet ferment of the
early church
that's i think that's interesting
because a lot of times christians today
i think get super obsessed with sort of
one of those you know save america
or
um save individual souls and if you read
the writings of the church fathers that
wasn't really the path that early
christians went what were they doing
they were like let's live the jesus way
let's live the jesus way and our hope is
people will see it and they will say
that is beautiful and i want some of it
and i'm joining with you guys
i'm doing a better path i'm going i want
a better life
and that's exactly what happened they've
been like they didn't have to grab the
reins of power force everyone bend them
to their will hey or shame them you know
you romans are terrible people and
didn't do it
they just lived their way
and people were captivated
drawn to it
now you say what do you mean by living
faithfully living their way living the
jesus way what do i mean i mean that
they believed that god is the god who is
father son holy spirit that god is and
that god is love in fact again he loves
so much he gave his one and only son to
die for sins and now through these
symbols this cross these cross like
through that picture this is the picture
of god's love right again not the cross
building caesar the cross-bearing one
that's the picture of love and people
said yes that is beautiful and i want to
pattern my life after that way of the
cross right the way that doesn't try to
assert power try to force but but the
way of suffering love
and they oriented themselves towards
that love
and and what happened was the fruit of
the god's spirit god's spirit sunk down
deep into them and a love and a joy and
a peace and a patience and a goodness
a faithfulness a gentleness a
self-control all the fruits of the
spirit galatians 5 22 and 23 started to
bubble up within them
and
people were drawn to it
they said that's beautiful and
good i want some of that and they joined
the jesus way and a few hundred years
later they changed rome a few thousand
years later they changed the course of
western civilization now you might ask
how did like well where did they learn
to do that this brings us back to our
text verse 17
peter calls his church back to something
very practical he says this respect
everyone
and love the family of believers
respect everyone love the family of
believers i don't know how that how does
that phrase strike you it's a little
love the family of believers i don't
know does that
you know
like it's interesting that in modern
times like i would probably never word
something like that and i would even be
hesitant to be like you know
love your church friends
you know like i don't know that just
doesn't have like that's one of those uh
creatures have a thing of you know
something will preach or something will
not preach
and i that would not like i know if i
titled like a message like hey so the
title of the message tonight is love
your church friends you know just be
like
what like
um
and i get it like there's
you know there's something we i think we
worry about being
cliquish
you know try but we've seen where
churches can get kind of the us for no
more syndrome you know and it's sort of
like yeah we're all tight against the
big bad world you know
so there's reasons i think historically
why you know i wouldn't preach a message
titled love your church friends love
your family into the family of believers
um and yet
and yet i do i do think
maybe
maybe the church is missing something
now since we don't preach messages like
that like i do wonder if we're kind of
losing
um basically the very place where
christians are formed
right like how do those little
communities learn that jesus way where
do they practice it
they practice it with the people to your
left and right
the people behind you and in front of
you
like that's the messy place where you
get into each other's lives and you
actually learn the ways the
kingdom if you're taking notes um well
actually before i do that let me name
this is a quote from richard beck he
says might the work of the kingdom
require a smaller more local and
intimate scale if it is to be practiced
relationally sustainably and
sacrificially
that's what he's naming
right might it actually take a local
community a family of believers who have
to like come together and actually like
know each other
and at times it's beautiful
kelly at the very beginning of service
mentioned some of that at times it's
beautiful and at times it's messy which
she would also be the first to admit at
times it's hard when you're in each
other's lives
and yet there's something so potent and
powerful there you're learning the jesus
way
if you're taking notes you can write
this down discipleship seeps into my
bones as i participate in christian
community and thereby learn to embody
the virtues of the kingdom of christ
that's a mouthful let me say it one more
time
discipleship seeps into my bones as i
participate in christian community and
thereby learn to embody the virtues of
the kingdom of christ in other words the
way i might sum that up is you pick up
the family values
by being part of the family
how else do you pick up the family
values
i mean that would be really hard to pick
up the family values who are like yeah
but i'm not really part of that family
you know you're like well okay
you pick up the family values by being
part of
the family
i was um
let me close with a few stories i was
maybe i was young
um my mom's here tonight so she might
know how how old were we
josh and i when we were doing meals on
wheels
do you remember was like
nine eight
eight or nine sir
so okay so i was probably nine and then
my brother was seven
so i remember so i was uh i was
homeschooled in my early years
um
and uh so we had this this little t i
don't know how long we did this for me
it seemed like a long time a year or
three or seven
um
but
but we would do this thing it was called
meals on wheels has anyone heard of
meals on wheels okay wow what this is
popular do you all do have you done
meals on wheels so you like drive around
okay no you just heard of it okay well
uh well we're hardcore so i know i'm
just sure um
so this was the thing so we're at nine
seven
and um
we would gather these meals basically
for those unfamiliar um meals on wheels
it's an organization that you deliver
meals to the homebound
um and folks
in need probably also um folks who are
poor because
you know they it's a free meal too
um
and so i remember my mother loaded us up
and my brother and i in our van
and
we are um driving around allen texas i
mean the band would just be filled with
these styrofoam containers just filled
with food i still remember the smell of
that food because we would deliver them
in the morning and i was so hungry even
though the smell wasn't great you know i
mean it wasn't like
five star you know what but
it was food and i was oh i would get so
hungry and we would just stack these up
and then remember we would drive around
we'd go to people's houses and my
brother and i we would switch off so
like one of us would be the holder of
the container you know this this um
this styrofoam container and then the
other would be like the knocker you know
and we would walk up and like ch and
they would open it up it was usually an
elderly person not always
and i can still remember you know smell
is such a powerful memory
you know thing it's so i can sort of
remember the smell of that food and the
smell of the houses
because you'd open that up right and
these were often homebound folks like
wasn't always pleasant you know i mean
sometimes but not always pleasant
and they would be so you know those i
think they were happy to see children
you know and they'll smile and they're
just oh hi there you know it's the
classic
cheek style you know
and i know i'm looking back on this
years later i think it's remarkable my
mom had us doing this and it was
interesting she didn't ask our
permission
did not ask if we wanted to be
doing that we just loaded up in the car
stacked up the meals and off we went now
what was going on there
teaching you the way you learn the
family values
by being part of the family
what were we doing we were learning how
to love
another memory i have i always
maybe
probably about the same age eight or
nine
and i'm in sunday school and i have a
sunday school teacher her name was um
pam bounds
and um
pam was remarkable i was my brother and
i were hellions in that church we were
noisy boys and just so we had that boy
energy
i see katie laughing because she helps
watch my kid my boys now are over there
right now you probably can hear them
sporadically yelling and screaming and
that was me i was terrible i was a bad
kid i i mean i wasn't back okay but i
just had that more energy you know i
just the last thing i wanted was to sit
there while anyone taught me about jesus
oh i just had no interest i wanted to
jump i wanted to run around oh i just
remember that i can still feel it like
in my body just
you know crazy
oh my gosh
but man pam bounced she was a miracle
worker
miracle work i remember she had that
just calm she was a schoolteacher as
well so she had the gift
so calm i remember she never screamed at
us i would have screamed in this i
couldn't take it that's a hard job over
there much harder than what i'm doing
and but she was always so calm and
although i can't remember consciously i
don't remember
any
lessons any principles any jesus sees
i'm sure the stories are back there
right because i know the stories of the
bible just kind of seep into your bones
you know so i know they're back there in
my subconscious and they help form who i
am but in terms of information like it's
i don't remember you know
um but i remember how she made me feel
loved
it's never left me
in fact i was thinking this week
reflecting on that experience like i
wonder to what degree because there's a
few of us in this room who are impacted
by pam bounds and was it like thinking
to what degree are the values in the
culture of the table church influenced
by pam bounds
a lady you've never met or heard of or
what what's going on there he learned
the family values by being part of the
family
i was learning to love
last memory i have i was
17 was my
junior year of high school
i went on a trip to minneapolis
minnesota
uh we were visiting homeless shelters
and um
each year we'd go on a mission trip the
theme was this pretty much the same
every trip it was
it's not about you
that was the theme of the trip
which can sound harsh
but if you know teenagers especially
middle class upper middle class maybe
just upper class teens lost in their own
glass cases of emotion and drama and
absolute self-centeredness
oh
it's a good theme it's not about you
[Laughter]
and we spent that week we just went from
shelter to shelter
and two things stood out to me one i saw
the the underbelly of american society
you know those
who um kind of forgotten
in a way
but sort of
almost pushed to the edges like we'd
rather not see you or interact with you
if possible you know and i
saw them and interacted with them i had
dinner with them over and over and over
and heard their stories and
i also saw christian people
running those shelters
quietly
think thanklessly
i mean presumably for years decades
maybe
some something was
being communicated there to me
beyond words or ideas
right it was it was seeping into my
bones in a million unspoken ways
what was i learning i was learning the
values of the kingdom you learn
the family values by being part of the
family i was learning to love
so how about you
how about you a
what are the things from your past
what's been forming you because here's
the thing as we've talked about now for
numerous messages we're always being
formed
we're always a part of some family
and of course hopefully you're catching
i'm not just talking about your literal
biological family
we're all part of some tribe we're all
part of some culture and oh you better
believe it is being something's being
communicated we are picking it up in a
million unspoken ways it is seeping into
our bones in every moment it's happening
now and sometimes there's good things
there sometimes not at all
and and so what are the things what's
influencing us what's
and then as you kind of bring it into
context into christian community what
are the things what are we learning here
again to be honest like sort of
self-critical both good and bad
right because the table's not some
perfect community it takes some
discernment to be a part of a christian
community and say what is in alignment
with the ways of christ here
and what where is the family missing it
that's an open question honestly it's
one we need to keep processing
but hopefully
hopefully there's
there's things here that remind you of
jesus and in my hope and my prayer is
that by participating in the family
you'll soak up the family values
so i guess that's the invitation is like
let's let's live it
let's let's do it
you see because this is how the kingdom
of god grows this is how the church
operates jesus said it's like it's like
uh yeast in dough
he said it's like mustard seeds in a
garden which are apparently sort of
weed-like they just grew and grew
he said that's how the kingdom happens
and that's how christ is formed in you
and how it forms in the world because
again this isn't about
if what you're hearing tonight this will
become more clear next week but if what
you're hearing tonight is you know just
a bunch of political quietism and like
just shut up and go to church you know
it's no you you're that's not quite true
um because what i'm getting at is it
starts here
it starts here and then what happens and
then it goes
and every interaction
you have then it spreads this is how the
kingdom of god
happens
can i pray for you
about your heads close your eyes
lord
jesus would you give us patience
we see so much wrong with the world in
our country and we just want to fix it
we want to change it all at once
help us to be patient
to trust your quiet in slow ways
lord would you do your good work in us
and through us
in the whole world
in the name of the father
and the son
and the holy spirit
amen
[Music]
thanks brett
i loved that phrase that he kept using
like learning the way of the family
learning the way of jesus um and it
reminded me of this song
that i learned a long time ago by a
friend of ours wrote it and his name is
jonathan rowell and it's called the way
you are and the chorus i just wanted to
say these lyrics real quick um hopefully
i can remember them correctly but it
says
the way you are tomorrow and today
the way your heart
courageously forgets when i miss my part
where you can make me live
and it's much more beautiful inside of
the song but what i love about those
lyrics is just
that grace that you find in the family
of god that's not the stringent the
stickler get it right you better get it
right you better get it right
but the courageous forgetfulness of god
that when we screw it up and we mess it
up and we
you know ruin everything
that he's just still wanting us to learn
the way that he is and the way he makes
us come to life and the way that he
infuses love and mercy into every little
pour of us in our communities
so anyways we're gonna sing this song
it's a fun one so
stand up with us have some fun in it
let's all join in together if we can um
because this is what this is what
families do right like i don't know if
y'all grew up going to family reunions
but i certainly did
and they are
bizarre
and weird but what i loved about it is i
came from a very traditionally christian
family and we would always have some
part during the weird weekend where
someone pulls out a guitar and we start
singing hymns and it's just a like you
know montage of off pitch and strange
you have grandma over there and you're
great aunt and your cousins and
everybody's just
singing out but there was something
beautiful in that because there was
space for everyone you know it was an
all play so that's that's what church
should be
so let's just uh join in with gary as he
leads us through this one let's have fun
with it
all right guys here we go
[Music]
we dream of you
on city streets
breathing again on our board
we dream of you
at kitchen sinks
your glory filling our home
[Music]
we are children
of grace
[Music]
is
we dream of you
on country roads
strolling along with our friends
leaving behind
flickering scream
to be together again
[Music]
we are children
of grace
and the blue
in our colors
is a garment
of praise
[Music]
we are children
of grace
[Music]
rejoice
let the earth rejoice
let the seas result
[Music]
and let the people sing the songs
let the people sing their songs
[Music]
[Applause]
cry out
let the rivers roll
let the people sing their songs
[Music]
we are children
of grace
[Music]
we are not
we are children
of grace
[Music]
rejoice
let the people sing the songs of joy
the rocks cry
let the rivers rolls
[Music]
[Applause]
let the rivers road
let the people sing their songs
[Music]
[Laughter]
that was fun that is really hard to
follow up guys thank you that was great
i'm like let's all stay after and we'll
just keep singing and dancing and move
it outside and
that is um good stuff and i know we are
like at the end of my time and i'm not
supposed to go over but i just wanted to
wrap up something i had shared in the
beginning it's just heavy on my heart in
light of the music and the songs and
everything else i mentioned we were in
chattanooga tennessee for nine years the
first three years we were part of a
church we both my husband and i grew up
in the church leaders in the church all
the things
and we ended up walking away from the
church and we fell in love with the
mountains when we were young and so we
are people who said
the mountains are our church being in
nature is our church hiking to this
waterfall that's our church and it was
and it was good and i do believe you can
meet god in nature in really profound
and beautiful ways i fully believe that
we got heavily involved in the running
community there and i love some of those
people dearly and that became again our
community was that group of people but
the thing and that was six years of
really diving in and getting to it was
good a lot of it was really really good
and powerful and sweet and i cherish
those memories and those people
but there came a time if you get injured
or you age out or you decide like i
don't want to do that distance or that
race and the running community isn't
there anymore and we we tasted that and
it um it hurt and it was sad and that's
a lot of people's experiences with all
different kinds of groups all of a
sudden you can't do this or you can't do
that and that group is now obsolete
to you and we found ourselves very
hungry and thirsty
for community that we grew up like rhett
was talking about that we grew up in our
childhood knowing and feeling at home
with
and attending the table online
and then our meetup group true i'm not
have no agenda here i don't know our
numbers i'm not supposed to say this and
say you should join a meetup group
but it became this really really safe
and sacred spot to be wounded to still
be invited on um you know
group runs bear with me you know not
literally a group run but still be
involved no matter where we were and
they meant it and other people were
sharing where they were and who they are
and it was all welcome and it was all
good and we were being inspired and
spurred on by good deeds with one
another and i
this church is such a sweet place and
the culture of it and the pace of it
that is moving from the music that is
chosen to what brett is preaching about
to the books that he's reading and then
sharing with us
that culture is being created in those
meetup groups so being a part of one is
a treasure trove that will stir your
heart to be filled and i highly
encourage it
and if you're not a part of one
um as you're leaving there's a little
table and i really encourage you to
write down your name number and get
plugged in at some capacity because it's
just so good and it's real people
who
want to be your real friend and really
introduce you to different versions of
the same god that we all know and love
so
that's i just felt like i really needed
and wanted to come back full circle and
share
why this place is so special to us
having tasted other um
other groups that are good and great but
not enough there is still something
missing
so fill out one of those forms if you're
interested in a meetup group and if you
want to know more about the table or you
want to become an official member on
february 20th that class will be going
on you can also fill out one of those
cards and get more information about
that
i'm going to close us out with a
benediction written by one of our
members here
and if you will just take a posture you
can sit stand close your eyes take a
deep breath open your hands
and just receive these words and at the
end i'm going to say peace with you and
you're going to say back to me and peace
be with you and then if you need prayer
or you want someone just to talk with i
will be up here and would love to be
that person for you
okay
you are a child of god
you are a child of god this is true on
your best day and it's true on your
worst day
so as you go into your week ahead with
its yet to be determined highs and lows
and everything in between go filled with
the assurance that you are loved
you are worthy
and you are accepted
just as you are
and go filled with god's holy spirit and
desire to extend these same gifts of
grace and unconditional love to everyone
you come in contact with
peace be with you
[Music]
you